the command senior enlisted leader of
the
u.s space command so this is obviously
the new branch of the military was
announced under president trump but this
guy's a 28-year
military veteran scott stalker he got
very upset because tucker carlson said
that pregnant women are not the most
lethal people on the planet
i understand some comments were made
yesterday and i watched the clip
that mr carlson produced as he referred
to pregnant women in the military
i'll remind everyone that his opinion
which he has a right to
is based off of actually zero days of
service in the armed forces
let me offer you my opinion my opinion
is based off of 28 years of actual
service in the military
28 years in the marine corps in combat
operations out at sea
and in garrison and so he was talking
specifically
about pregnant women in the armed forces
today and how it makes us
less lethal and less fit and less ready
let me tell you where he's wrong
those decisions were made by medical
professionals by commanders
and our civilian leadership that allows
for women to have more time with their
children
to recuperate to get fit and ready
to take that time that's necessary that
our medical professionals know
is needed which makes actually makes us
a more lethal
and ready and fit force let's remember
that those opinions were made by an
individual
who has never served a day in his life
28 years experience this guy has
he's got an impressive credential he's
got this blue check mark on twitter
which is reflective of his position as a
senior enlisted leader
and not one iota of common sense
now one little bit
the decision to have women in the
military the decision more recent
decision of women in combat roles
that was a political decision that was
not a tactical decision
i understand the political arguments for
it the political arguments were that
if we're going to have true equality for
women if we're not going to have women
underneath the patriarchy
then they need to be able to do all the
wonderful privileges that
and get all the wonderful privileges
that men have including
uh fighting in war and dodging bullets
and and all that sort of thing this is
considered some privilege
and so therefore because of that as a
political matter we need to let women
uh fight and now this is being taken
even to the craziest extreme
which is we need to let pregnant women
fight or something we need we
break we need we need to pretend that
pregnant women
are just as fit and lethal as men are
they do i've learned have a very lethal
and acerbic
tongue and wit sometimes i've learned
this through my own experience with
pregnant women but in terms of
physicality
it's just not the case as a tactical
matter
men are bigger faster and physically
stronger
than women and certainly than pregnant
women there's no question about that
the whole reason that we're even
debating the tran
the trans women right the men playing in
women's sports
issue is because men beat women in
women's sports
because men and women are different and
men are physically
stronger than women now you'll notice
here this guy
stalker he he's come there he's in his
uniform he says look tucker carlson that
guy never served a day in his life not
like me
so that journalist he has no right you
know sure he can have his opinion but
he's wrong
he's never served ever in his life uh
and i'm gonna debunk his arguments and
then what does he do
he never addresses his argument he just
says women
are in the military and that's good
you're like okay well
yes they are in the military that's
objectively true you think it's good
that pregnant women are
fighting i don't think that's good i
think that's bad but you
and then he sort of said he's like and
they they need to rest up so they can be
physically fit again you say well that's
not what anybody's even talking about
mr stalker so then there was a little
bit of a backlash
stalker decides he's going to issue a
non-apology apology
wow last 24 hours have been pretty
intense for me ladies and gentlemen
and i just wanted to briefly say thank
you to everyone that
wrote me that everyone that called
texted sent me a message on twitter or
facebook
i appreciate it and i even appreciate
the fact that those of you had different
opinions
uh posted those as well what i won't do
is engage in a personal attack with mr
carlson
or anybody i don't believe in doing that
i think that my comments stand on
themselves
i was making a non-political statement
about my service members and teammates
in the united states armed forces i
don't make political comments and i
certainly don't attack our media
i think they have a right and it's a
necessity of this nation to have a fair
and free press and so
mr carlson and everyone that's reporting
stories please continue to do so
i think it's important that i just make
a comment that i say
my comments are based on 28 years of
service he doesn't have any service
that does not mean his his points aren't
valid
and so i think everyone has a right to
their opinion does not mean his points
are invalid i mean my whole video
was about how his points aren't valid
and uh
look i'm saying it's not a personal
attack i mean my whole video was
personally attacking
tucker carlson but look it wasn't
political okay even though
my entire video was making political
points notice
how quick that guy took his uniform off
you know that first one he's got the
uniform on he's using it
to make his entire point is basically
that tucker carlson is wrong and we
shouldn't take him seriously anyway
because he's never served in the
military not like me
not like me mr stalker now all that goes
away because of the backlash
the whole video was claiming that
tucker's points are invalid the military
would seem to disagree though there's a
new report out research
showed that the army combat fitness test
it's the same one for male and female
soldiers
was leading to lower results for women
an early pentagon study this is
according to the telegraph
said that women were failing the acft at
a rate of 65 percent
well only well 90 of men were passing
the a
c f t i'm not saying this to denigrate
women
i'm sure these women are extremely
strong but men and women are different
and men are physically stronger than
women that is why
historically speaking warriors have been
men this is outrage i mean this guy
should obviously lose his leadership
position there's there is no question
about that
he should have his twitter account taken
away from him by his
by his bosses in the military right by
by the top brass
but but also he should lose his
leadership position this is an
incredible abuse of power and it's also
just profoundly stupid
what he's saying doesn't make any sense
and it is so dispiriting for for
supporters of the military
to to listen to this woke nonsense out
of
out of someone who's in a leadership
position it would be good if this guy
could apologize but he can't apologize
because our culture
has made that almost impossible i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the michael
knowles show
to check out the full episode hit the
link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you